selon les hypothèses nous sommes sur du
remblai il ya de l'eau souterraine
nous sommes en train de faire des
sondages pour déterminer précisément
l'origine est ce que c'est une
rupture d'une canalisation d'eau potable
ça peut se faire parce que le lot a été
analysé elle est chlorée
est ce que c'est les derniers bruits en
tout cas les vibrations par les
transporteurs routiers lourds la manche
pas les choses donc ce sont les
techniciens actuellement qui font les
sondages et que mon pouvoir que les
préconisations pour la profondeur la
situation est sérieuse parce que je suis
ou 55 m et un glissement les acteurs
glisse vers le vivier roche donc sommes
en train de faire des investigations
géotechniques pour déterminer l'ampleur
du glissement et pour chercher à voir
comment le stopper
réconforté la route malheureusement dans
l'intervalle où les raisons de sécurité
d'un publi ged interrompre la
circulation dont le faire pendant le
week end et plus de trains jusqu'à
nouvel ordre des cas vous allez hop est
un axe aussi important ça fait un report
sur les longueurs mais heureusement il
n'y a d'autre moyen d'atteindre
l'établissement scolaire de dillon et à
d'autres emplois celle pas le seul
itinéraire mais ça va surtout poser un
problème pour les transporteurs de
marchandises le canal ont imposé de fait
une déviation par maurice bishop six
valeureux jeunes l'autoroute et ceux qui
viennent de chateauboeuf évidemment ils
pourront pas utiliser l'échangeur pour
rejoindre le dos